the biggest gathering London has seen in
weeks and one of the most passionate
[Music]
protesters were peaceful but angry about
George Floyd's death in the u.s. that
America's woes of inequality and racism
resonated in their lives here
Star Wars starred John boyega
said it was time for change police
chiefs in the UK offered a message of
solidarity to the protesters saying they
too were appalled and horrified by mr.
Floyd's death but that didn't go down
well here in this country we talked and
we're heading for central London police
were issued a warning saying that the
virus is still out there there are still
restrictions in place to prevent its
spread including people live gathering
in groups of more than six people and
staying two metres apart but clearly
that's not happening
people here felt they needed to come
together to make their message loud and
clear there were no mass-produced
placards just simple messages on cargo
and just as police couldn't enforce
social distancing they didn't properly
cordon the route as the March weaved
through traffic on Hyde Park Corner
[Music]
George Floyd died in Minneapolis after a
police officer put a knee on his neck
for eight minutes
it has parallels with Sean Riggs death
in Brixton in 2008 after being held
facedown for several minutes by police
officers
Sean's sister Marcia says families of
those who've died in custody have
recently written asking to meet the
Prime Minister I want people to know
that this has been happening in the
United Kingdom for decades as well
including with my brother Sean and to
see that video on the TV was so
traumatic for me because it just brought
brought my experience back I've shown
it's like it happened yesterday I want
to meet him with Boris Johnson so I
could speak on behalf of all the
families that cannot do it I'm here to
do it for them because I know what it's
like as the protests reached Downey
Street there were some scuffles between
police and protesters
[Music]
but in Brixton there was a more peaceful
moment of reflection farmer were among
those paying tribute to the black lives
matter cause one man's death has
rekindled this movement around the world
and shown that a pandemic can't stop
protests
Jason Farrell Sky News